We get support from UC Davis, a globally ranked university, working to solve the world's most pressing problems in food, energy, health, education, and the environment. UC Davis researchers collaborate and innovate in California and around the globe to find transformational solutions. It's all part of the university's mission to promote quality of life for all living things. Find out more at 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. Beethoven continued to write music and wrote some of his best music after he lost his hearing. So he couldn't hear his music at all.
我们得到了加州大学戴维斯分校的支持，这是一所全球知名的大学，致力于解决世界在食品、能源、健康、教育和环境方面最紧迫的问题。加州大学戴维斯分校的研究人员在加利福尼亚及全球各地合作创新，以寻找变革性的解决方案。这都是该大学促进所有生物生活质量使命的一部分。请访问 21stCentury.ucdavis.edu 了解更多信息。这里是《99%无形》。我是罗曼·马斯。贝多芬在失聪后继续创作音乐，并创作了他一些最好的音乐。所以他根本听不到自己的音乐。
He could only hear the construction in his mind. And as architects, we have all sorts of different ways of experiencing architecture, both in its built form, in its creation, through tactile drawings and models, besides our own mental constructions. So Chris Downey asks me, what's more preposterous? Composing music you can't hear, or designing architecture, you can't see.
他只能听到自己心中的建筑。作为建筑师，我们有各种各样不同的方式来体验建筑，无论是在其建成形式、创作过程中，通过触觉图纸和模型，还是通过我们自己的心理构建。所以克里斯·唐尼问我，哪个更荒谬？创作你听不到的音乐，还是设计你看不见的建筑。
My name is Chris Downey. I'm an architect. In case you haven't guessed it yet, he is a blind architect. Chris Downey lost his sight about three years ago after being an architect for nearly two decades. Clearly there wasn't any book out there on how to be a blind architect. So really the best thing to do it is just to get out there and try. And once I did that, it quickly realized that there are ways to perceive and understand drawings in design, both in two-dimensional form and in three-dimensional form, and there are any number of ways to react to it and advance it, create it, just like anybody else.
我叫克里斯·唐尼。我是一名建筑师。如果你还没猜到的话，他是一位失明的建筑师。克里斯·唐尼在做了近二十年建筑师后，大约三年前失去了视力。显然，当时没有任何关于如何成为一名盲人建筑师的书籍。所以真正最好的做法就是走出去尝试。一旦我这样做了，我很快意识到，有各种各样的方法来感知和理解设计中的图纸，无论是二维形式还是三维形式，并且有无数种方法来对此做出反应、推进和创造，就像其他人一样。
The only thing he couldn't do ultimately was translate the physical models that he can make by hand into data that he can input into a computer design program. But hey, that's not all bad. Quite frankly, it's kind of nice to have it excuse. Not to have to be the production guy. You can get past that and focus on where I could really deliver value. It started following together pretty well after that.
他最终唯一做不到的事情，是将他可以手工制作的物理模型转化为可以输入到计算机设计程序中的数据。不过嘿，这也不算太坏。坦白说，有个借口不用做制作人员感觉挺不错的。你可以越过那一关，专注于我真正能够创造价值的地方。从那以后，事情开始变得顺利起来。
The key is finding the right tools. In this case, computers that talk really fast. Maybe they're the ones that have a little bit of the fastest one of five. So that's the final one of print. I can slow it down. That might be an easier rate to hear it. If you had to listen to that all day long, that's how fast the ATM machines are. When you go and listen to those
关键是找到正确的工具。在这种情况下，是说话速度非常快的计算机。也许它们是五个中最快的一个。所以这是最终打印的一个。我可以把它放慢。这可能是一个更容易听懂的速率。如果你不得不一整天都听那个，那就是自动取款机的速度。当你去听那些
to have your non-visual access to it, and it takes so long to get to what you need to do. You gotta be faster, so you learn them, but speed less. Remember, like I'll be able to look there, but you can even do that one. Another key tool is an embossing printer
为了非视觉地访问它，而达到你需要做的事情需要这么长时间。你必须更快，所以你学会了它们，但速度会下降。记住，就像我能看到那里，但你甚至可以做到那个。另一个关键工具是压花打印机
that makes a raised braille.version of the architectural plans that he's working on, unlike a sighted architect that can get a bird's eye view of an architectural plan. When Downey runs his fingers over the embossed printed page, he experiences the plan more like an actual person traveling through the building wood as a sequence of vignettes. When you do that, then you have a better chance of really putting yourself in that space and thinking about everything that's happening when you move through there. The typical sensory experience of the environment around us, 80% of it, is visual.
它可以制作他正在从事的建筑图纸的凸起盲文版本。与能够鸟瞰建筑图纸的明眼建筑师不同，当唐尼的手指滑过压花打印页面时，他体验图纸的方式更像是一个实际穿过建筑的人，将其作为一系列小插画。当你这样做时，你就有更好的机会真正把自己置身于那个空间中，并思考当你穿过那里时发生的一切。我们周围环境的典型感官体验，其中80%是视觉的。
When your brain isn't overloaded with the visual information, the other 20% becomes a lot more important and this allows for a new appreciation for certain buildings. Like for example, a much hated old San Francisco bus terminal. The Transbay Terminals coming down, and that old space that was there, it was not a particularly delightful place. Visually it was a horrific place. All factory experience was pretty miserable too. It tended to smell like urine.
当你的大脑没有被视觉信息超载时，其余的20%就变得重要得多，这使得人们能够对某些建筑产生新的欣赏。例如，一个备受讨厌的旧旧金山公交总站。跨湾总站正在拆除，那里旧的空间并不是一个特别令人愉快的地方。从视觉上看，这是一个可怕的地方。所有的工厂体验也相当糟糕。它往往闻起来像尿液。
But I was lucky enough to have lost my sight and my smell. So it didn't look bad and it didn't smell bad. And there are a lot of these long ramps and incline planes if you're blind are great because all of a sudden you get directionality out of gravity, regardless of whichever way you're going up or down. If you're going uphill, you can get a strong sense of going straight uphill as opposed to sort of going off on an angle and coming downhill.
但我很幸运，我失去了视力，也失去了嗅觉。所以它看起来不坏，闻起来也不坏。这里有很多长斜坡和倾斜平面，如果你是盲人，这些地方太棒了，因为无论你往上还是往下走，重力突然间赋予了你方向感。如果你在上坡，你可以获得一种强烈的直接上坡的感觉，而不是那种有点偏离角度然后下坡的感觉。
You just make like a drop of water and just fall to gravity. So those were actually kind of fun spaces. So if you ever wondered what it would take to love the old Trans Bay Terminal, the in blind and having no sense of smell seems to do the trick. Something I often talk about is sort of the touch of a building where you actually reach out and grab the building, whether it's a door handle or a railing or a place to lean against or a place to sit down. If those places offer the warmth of a comfortable touch, something that acknowledges the presence of the body besides the agenda of the eyes, you know, How can you think about the material or the form
你就像一滴水一样顺着重力落下。所以这些其实是相当有趣的空间。因此，如果你曾好奇是什么让人想要爱上旧的跨湾总站，那就是失明且没有嗅觉似乎就能奏效。我经常谈论的一件事是建筑的触感，你实际伸手去抓建筑，无论是门把手、栏杆、靠着的地方还是坐下的地方。如果这些地方提供了舒适触感的温暖，一种承认身体存在而非仅仅迎合眼睛意图的东西，你知道，你如何思考材料或形式
in a way that gives you that handshake, just like you give somebody a handshake? There's a lot that's communicated through a handshake. And so what's the handshake of the building? What are you saying in that handshake? Fun and more about Chris Downey at 99%Invisible.org. Yeah. 99% Invisible is produced by me, Roman Mars, with support from Lunar.
以一种给你这种握手感的方式，就像你和别人握手一样？握手传递了很多信息。那么建筑的握手是什么？你在那个握手中表达了什么？在 99%Invisible.org 上了解更多关于克里斯·唐尼的信息。是的。《99%无形》由我罗曼·马斯制作，并得到了 Lunar 的支持。
It's a project of KALW, the American Institute of Architects San Francisco, in the center for architecture and design. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是 KALW、美国建筑师学会旧金山分会以及建筑与设计中心的合作项目。这一集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。